on montre aujourd'hui comme il ya 40 ans
toute la qualité de l'agriculture de
notre département avec une agriculture
très diversifié est-ce qu'on veut
surtout montrer c'est que on est deux
sur un territoire tels que par exemple
la vallée du loir où l'agriculture est
vraiment un facteur déterminant pour son
avenir
je veux dire par là que l'importance que
l'on présente au commises par les
éleveurs que ce soit les éleveurs de
moutons comme ici on est là mais elle
est aussi les chevaux mais surtout les
bovins c'est primordial que si on veut
conserver une agriculture et un
territoire vivant si on a perdu mais
l'agriculteur en très peu de temps
moi je suis beaucoup plus sur le dossier
production animale on était encore plus
de 300 producteurs de lait il ya une
bonne dizaine d'années aujourd'hui nous
sommes plus que 150 et on s'aperçoit que
le moral n'y est pas actuellement dans
le puits ce qui nous est fait avant que
la pac l'abandon des quotas laitiers
alors là c'est vraiment la bérézina
parce que mon sens que si l'électrique
emmène le dossier toutefois nous paie
des opinions bien vouloir
sachant qu'en plus ils sont cousines en
train de se délocaliser vers les pays
étrangers on n'a pas l'impression qu'on
a un gouvernement qui prend en
considération la demande des éleveurs et
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure c'est qu'au
niveau du comice on a dit super
présenter
tiens à remercier tous les exposants
éleveurs de quelque part on a tous les
volumes qui sont tellement dans la
tourmente qu'ils ont préféré rester chez
eux et ça c'est pire que les présents la
nuit